hey reject nation its Greg Alva here cat
Alvarado vulnera duck at Alvarado on
Instagram and Twitter and cash are doing
comedy you know on the streets because
they don't let her into clubs anymore
just like that is what I got today
people - so how does that I had her a
coma reporter just a big surprise lol
alright this was sent to me today and I
said fine sure I got cat coming by let's
do it while you saw it here live just
about a half hour ago hundreds of people
descending on the Hermosa Beach to begin
a uni melon Ironman competition yes it
includes running paddling and drinking
beer Wendy birch in the middle of the
action
good morning yeah I was I was doing like
this but I was in the middle the mosh
pit a lot of people who are you know one
owner now come on over here my friend hi
I again get ugly this is the true test
of endurance now let's just recap you
guys ran a mile on the beach yet paddled
a mile in the ocean and now what are you
doing there you big baby I'm going to
sit back where I feel that you
this Christian love it this is my friend
Sarah Sarah was trying to finish your
success you've been training for this
for some time in about 25 years
Oh celebration hydrogen gentlemen time
to bring her out okay okay we saw
everything in that live shot yeah joy
yeah where's our toy what I okay all
right and we're gone when do you get out
of there baby let's do it before you get
cover and something other than beer yeah
all right play that thank you what has
happened to journalists this is our
nation looks like beer vomit it looks
like vomit it doesn't look like but
that's projectile I mean we could really
go dirtier and call it something else
this is new and any other not that much
yeah we were safe this is
age-appropriate content this woman
signed up to be a reporter and this is
what she covers what is this event
it's a triathlon so you throw a female
reporter in the midst of a mosh pit of a
bunch of bad guys bad guys and they ran
a model I don't think these guys ran our
a magic one Ironman I like you know you
know Mary several miles women like not a
mile in a bunch of year more than like
50 minutes migrants what was happening
here with that woman bent over was it
like a message just pour some beer I
like a whole minute what was happening I
really are they doing imagine like you
something sexual okay
oh she's peachy keen so she's puking
another friend that's yeah dream of
orders Fred
I'm here does the reporter seem a little
bit drunk at the beginning I think she's
I think she had to get a little bit
drunk I I was a reporter and this was
the story they put me on for
man-on-the-street news I would be a
little bit embarrassed to be like this
is what I'm covering think you can yeah
if I miss her in the reporter and pretty
sure would be a little bit drunk always
and of course you send the female
reporter into this exact is that got a
friend for safety that one for safety
buddy friend oh man that was horrible
man I could see doing this job one day
you know what comedy fails for you and
then you decided like try some
hard-hitting journalism in Los Angeles
it's too real great
this is could be used this is this is
the new cat
oh poor cat smaller more surrounded by a
bunch more sexually attractive now we'd
improvement most likely inside jokes
people but it's not doing that anymore
here's of comments covered in white
substance ha ha ha Thank You wonderful
ha got me Internet yeah just like one to
leave and I like the way the the anchors
handle that situation to their shopping
which but they were also embarrassed to
be part of ktla 5 News at the time uh
well guys thanks for setting that to us
that was well worth it I'm glad that you
know I thought journalism was low the
fact that we are reacting and talking
about it were even lower now subscribe
to the real rejects right click that
notification belt cat Alvarado the
lovely cat Alvarado is not her name on
why it's not that many Alvarado yeah
follow her their Instagram Twitter your
Facebook fan page thank you can i watch
comedy I put that in D s I remembered
our remember thing
now you're the personal Facebook to
friend requester see if she accepts it
tonight
she has she still is accepted mine which
is kind of a shame I try to send you a
lot of pics
I've seen them yeah there's a reason I
haven't accepted your friend request you
should do reactions to the pictures
actually Center